je m'appelle dit lily une princesse qui
vient de l'autre bout de la terre
en avant vers paris non 1re journée dont
c'était extraordinaire
quel bonheur d'être avec toi dans ton
triporteur une autre fillette enlevée
les mâles m ont encore frappé
nous percevrons le mystère des mâles
mais entendu je connais beaucoup de
monde
monsieur pasto que savez-vous des
ravisseurs de viviez rien hélas si ce
n'est une rumeur raconte que le moulin
rouge est devenue un repaire de mal m
de toulouse lautrec
jeb autres suspects regardez ce texte
dans une demi-heure attaques de
bijouteries paraît joli pari pouilles
nous produisons kidon petite que la
personne la plus recherchée par les
mâles m
nous n'attendrons pas pour délivrer les
petites prisonniers la sphère est fait
interdiction livrer dit baby
nous devons maintenant de protéger
monsieur nous sommes prêts à tout pour
mettre hors d'état de nuire les mâles
mer
délivreront aux clients et cela ne fait
que commencer
[Musique]